[MUSIC PLAYING]
FILIP: Hello.
Welcome to "The Boring
Show," episode four.
With me today is Matt.
MATT: Andrew couldn't
make it today,
so I'm the stopgap,
again, for this episode.
FILIP: Yep.
I'm Filip.
I'm still Filip.
I'm back from vacation.
I don't know anything
about Flutter anymore.
So this will be interesting.
I forgot everything.
MATT: You should see
what we did last week.
FILIP: I did kind of see it.
But yeah, it's all good.
So we're going to--
so just like a
refresher, "Boring Show"
is here to kind of
show the development
of Flutter apps in a way
that's not edited at all.
So there's all the
errors, and warts,
and everything is in, so
that you have a chance
to see us fail in
a spectacular way,
and maybe learn something how
we can recover, hopefully,
of all these things.
And you know, it's "Boring
Show" because it's long.
It's often one hour.
And what we're trying to do is,
for the last three episodes,
we've been slowly--
or actually, pretty fast.
We spend three hours building
a Hacker News reader app.
And since what I saw last
time, you guys went to--
you already have networking in.
Right?
MATT: Yep.
So what we did last time,
we took Built Value,
and we wrapped--
built our data classes
with those, which
gave us JSON serialization.
And so when we had
that, what we did was
we quickly added
networking, which
was pretty straightforward.
And from there, we
went back to the UI,
and we started to pull in
the data over the network,
using a FutureBuilder
to pull it in.
So now you are with the
app in its current state.
You're able to get the
top stories, I believe.
And you're able
to click on them.
And then we used the
URL Launcher Package
to let you fullscreen, actually,
browse the URL for each story.
FILIP: And so, and it all works.
Actually, as you can
see on my screen,
we can read the stories.
We can launch them in
whatever the system gives you
as the web browser.
So that's all great.
I think we've accrued
for the past three
episodes some technical debt.
So that's what
we're going to fix.
MATT: We accrued a lot of
technical debt last episode.
Which now that you're
back, you can fix.
So that's great.
FILIP: No, no, no.
I think for the whole thing.
And that's an interesting
part, because nobody
wants to deal with that,
especially not on video.
But we'll try and fix some
of the most glaring issues.
So that's the first part.
And if we have time to
delve more into stuff,
there's been a lot of you
asking for state management.
How do know I work out-- how
do I not mix [? V-Logic ?]
and business logic and all that?
And so we're in the same set up.
If you've seen the I/O talk
that we gave with Matt,
that was about state management.
So who else?
All right.
MATT: So that should be
pretty quick, because we
know what we're doing.
FILIP: And it won't.
But we'll see that.
So--
MATT: All right.
Where are we starting?
FILIP: We're starting
with the technical debt.
Right?
MATT: OK.
FILIP: So we started
this project way,
way back in, I think, February,
when we recorded the first one.
And at that time, new was still
a thing, so the keyword new.
I just want to make sure that
we don't have new anywhere.
And that's pretty--
OK.
So we don't have new here.
This is all commented
out for some reason.
MATT: Oh, that's the
old JSON parsing code.
FILIP: Oh, OK.
So let's just-- OK.
Part of it is just deleted
things that we don't use.
OK.
Save, Delete.
Did it do that?
Looks like it didn't delete.
MATT: Are you sure nothing
is still use in there?
Because we have article.
But where do we parse the--
there was-- we
parse the original.
There's a list of IDs
that come through.
FILIP: Oh.
MATT: So we might
still be using that.
FILIP: Yeah.
We are.
And it's in the JSON test.
OK.
That's a good one.
So we will delete that.
And in JSON test--
what did we--?
Oh.
This is all commented out.
And this is actually
no longer here,
because you put it into
article, which makes sense.
MATT: Yep.
So we're going to be using
the serializer, which
comes from serializers.dart.
FILIP: Yes.
All right.
So that fixes that.
Let me see.
OK.
News.
There should be no news here.
We're still on-- OK.
A lot of commented out stuff.
Oh, I love deleting code.
Cool.
I'm just going to assume that
this is there for some reason
that we don't need
to care about.
MATT: So that's
for parsing the--
because when you make
the first network call,
it pulls back a
list of integer IDs.
And wrapping that in Built
Value seemed like overkill,
because it's just a
list of integer IDs.
But when we parse
the article, we
have constructed the
serializer automatically
using Built Value,
because a ton of stuff.
FILIP: Right.
Right.
Which is great.
So I think I got rid
of all the news here.
So that's great.
So I'm going to commit.
We didn't actually
get rid of comments.
Delete stuff.
MATT: Delete stuff.
There we go.
A very descriptive
GitHub comment.
FILIP: Yes, yes, yes.
You will need that.
So that's news.
Do we need to refactor
names of anything?
So I'm pretty OK
with the article.
I'm also OK with
serializers, obviously.
We still have only
one widget, which is--
MATT: So you have a list of--
that [? prop ?] list
of IDs is probably
being pulled automatically now.
FILIP: I think it's not.
I think we're
still-- because you
see, I remember in
the last episode,
you were also looking
at why nobody ever
wins the car at the mall.
MATT: Oh.
We haven't actually--
FILIP: So, yeah.
Which is fine.
We'll have that as
a to-do item today.
MATT: Yeah.
We should fix that up.
FILIP: In terms of names,
I think we're fine.
We don't have widgets
outside the MyApp.
It can still be MyApp.
MATT: Our tree's pretty
shallow at the moment anyway.
FILIP: Yes, yes.
Which is fine.
That's great.
Testing.
So we have the JSON [INAUDIBLE].
Let's run it.
So there's at least two
things that will break now.
All right.
So the widget test is breaking,
because it isn't actually
waiting for the data to
load from the network.
We haven't instrumented the
app so that we can actually
give it some things
not from the network.
So even in that
test, we're actually
asking for the network,
which we could fix, but let's
not do that now.
Let's just leave
it be, and we can
maybe at the end of this
episode or in the next episode,
we can instrument
it so that it works.
MATT: OK.
FILIP: The JSON, I'm a
little more worried about.
So we have-- this works.
So the parsed up stories works.
That's great.
This also works.
This seems to have
a problem here.
And that's that--
oh, we are actually
assuming that the first article
that we get from the best
stories will always be authored
by a D. Houston, which is not
true.
So that was never a good test.
So let's--
MATT: What you could do
here is we could simply
check that some of these
fields are not null.
FILIP: Exactly.
Yes.
Is not null.
Right.
So if I run it again, again,
the widget test will fail.
But these should not fail.
And another thing
that I want to do is--
and I know you talked
about this before.
But this might want
a longer timeout.
I think that the
timeout for a test
is something like
the default one is--
what's the default timeout?
I won't figure it out now.
But it's probably shorter than
we want for a networking call.
Also, networking
call in a unit test
is probably not a great idea.
MATT: No, you're talking
more integration [? test. ?]
FILIP: Yes.
But--
MATT: But at least
get this one working.
FILIP: Yes.
And that's probably the best.
Because normally, you
would do a different file,
and there you would try this.
It's definitely better
to have it in a test.
I'm just going to do and
skip this one by default,
so that our tests run faster.
That's what I do normally.
And if you want to, so like
on really long-running tests,
you either just skip, and
then you do something like--
so normally, you
do a Flutter test.
Not Flutter rust.
Flutter test.
MATT: Have you been
writing rust code?
FILIP: No.
So this will fail,
and I'll add--
if you want.
But our two tests
that we wanted,
two tests actually run through.
That's great.
And you see here--
that's not very-- but so you
see that one of them failed.
Two of them passed.
And one of them was skipped.
MATT: OK.
So it skipped the one
that you marked as true,
and the other one that's
failing is the widget
test that we're going to fix
at some point in the future.
FILIP: Yes.
And I thought there
was a Skipped option.
So Flutter test help.
OK.
I'm thinking about another one.
But anyway, so it's
possible to say, hey,
I want to also run
the skipped tests.
What I can do is, if you
just do [? prop ?] run test,
I think like this.
Oh, I have another dot.
Anyway, you have to
trust me for this one.
All right.
So with this, and I'm just going
to also maybe skip this one so
that we can easily just--
MATT: But we're going
to come back to this.
FILIP: Yes.
MATT: And again, best
practice that-- well,
practice that I
certainly have done,
is when I'm doing
network calls, I
tend to just make some
random network calls,
save the JSON in a
JSON file, add it
in an Assets folder
for testing, and then
I just use that for my tests.
FILIP: Yes.
MATT: Which is a lot better than
having to rely on your network
being available all the time.
FILIP: Yes.
MATT: Cool, cool.
FILIP: So we have
got all our tests
working by skipping
the tests that broke.
Great.
OK.
[LAUGHING]
And that's how you deal
with technical debt.
MATT: Yes.
[LAUGHING]
FILIP: I also-- I think
I had another one here.
So we have the
parsed up stories.
And I think what
you're doing here
is, basically, you're
decoding this as if you
didn't have parsed up stories.
So what I'm going to do
here is just do that.
MATT: Oh, OK.
FILIP: And just a little one.
So, OK.
So another comment,
deal with tests.
OK.
Yeah, we did remove some
commented out files.
Oh, one thing that I saw here
is that there is this line end
comment that basically says,
OK, these are the types
that we expect this to have.
We could have this as an
enum value, for example.
But I think it's fine
to have it as a string.
I just think this could be
done as a document instead
of a comment at the
end of the line.
So another thing
about technical debts,
often you don't have
as much documentation
as you would like.
I just wanted to introduce
the documents in Dart.
Documents are great because--
so, I'm not going to spend
too much time coming up
with a good text.
But this is the type of article.
And then, it can be either--
MATT: And of.
FILIP: --any of these.
And so what I want to show you
is now whenever you use article
anywhere, like here, and
you're like, OK, so type,
it will show up in your ID.
Is this really small?
So you can do a bunch of things
and reach comments, and all
that.
But what Dart has a
really good thing about
is these documentation comments.
And documentation
comments are just,
you put them in
front of anything
that you want to
document, and then
you use three instead
of two slashes.
MATT: So one thing we might want
to explore, maybe not today,
but later, is that Built
Value has its own enum type.
Or, sorry, not eunum type, but--
FILIP: That's true.
MATT: --support for building
an enum class, which gives you
much richer functionality
than the out of the box
enums from Dart.
In fact, we were talking
to David Morgan, who
wrote "The Library Today," and
he came from a Java background.
So the support for
enums in Built Value
is more like Java enums
in his Dart enums.
It might well be suitable
here, because everything plays
well together in Built Value.
So maybe in the future, we
could look at swapping that out
with an enum, and that
might make our life easier.
FILIP: Yes, absolutely.
MATT: Something to
consider for another time.
FILIP: Yes.
That's a really good idea.
One thing that I also
wanted to mention
is that I just
found out yesterday
about this amazing tool
called json2builtvalue,
which is done by--
I forgot the name.
By Rafal.
And this is amazing, because--
let's see if we can--
this basically is, you
just put JSON here.
And you say, oh, I want the
root dot object to be article.
And you click Convert,
and suddenly you
have just, like, all
the things that you guys
did for 30 minutes.
You have it right here.
Obviously, it cannot detect
nullable fields and stuff like
this, so you'll still need
to actually understand what
you're doing.
But this can really help a lot.
And it already has
it to JSON from JSON.
MATT: It gives you a lot
of the-- it gives you
all the boiler plate.
And you can tweak
this for nullable
and not nullable and
whatnot afterwards.
But Filip is really
trying to say
that the 30 minutes of Built
Value that we sweated blood
and tears over in
the last episode
has been replaced
with a web app.
FILIP: Yes, yes.
You have been automated.
Sorry.
So, cool.
So definitely check this out.
And I think this
also is a nice way
of showing that this
is built-in Dart,
and Dart can do webs as well.
So you can either go and see
how Rafal made this happen,
but also, if you don't
want to just go and install
a thing or whatever, you
can just go to the website
and put this in,
and you're done.
MATT: This is like "Inception."
We have a web app
written in Dart
to generate Dart code, which
is then used by Built Value
to generate more Dart code.
FILIP: Dart code that
then communicates
with a web interface.
MATT: And the
circle is complete.
FILIP: Yes.
All right.
So OK.
I hope this is
not underwhelming,
but I'm pretty happy with the
state of our code base now.
Obviously, we'd want
to document more.
We'd want to make sure
that the tests actually
do something and all that.
But we're kind of in a place.
Oh, I made this change, so
let me just put this here.
So at docs.
All right.
So now, we are getting to
the meat of this episode,
and that is state management.
MATT: OK.
So we're going to
play with streams.
FILIP: That's right.
Yeah.
MATT: OK.
Cool.
So set the stage.
Why do we need state?
What are we going to be doing?
FILIP: So we currently,
as this is implemented,
we have our business logic
right inside our widget.
MATT: We're making the network
call inside our widget.
We're using a FutureBuilder,
then, to handle all that.
So basically our UI and our
network code is just munged
together into this
big main .dart file.
FILIP: Correct.
Yes.
Also, it looks like--
it's also a bit less testable
now, because the app doesn't--
well, it depends on networking.
So that's why we have all these
problems with the widget test.
And it's just nicer to
have things separate.
MATT: OK.
FILIP: So that's what
we're going to do.
We're going to use BLoC, which
we talked about on our talk
at I/O. We could
do anything else.
We could actually
go with set state.
We could go with
inherited widget.
MATT: We could go
with scoped model.
We could go with Redux.
But we're going to try
the BLoC stream method.
FILIP: Yeah, Yeah.
I think it makes a lot of
sense, especially here, where
the actual thing
that you see here
is more or less a
stream of use, really.
MATT: That's true.
FILIP: So OK.
So we are going to do that.
And again, this is where I'm
going to be a little lost,
because I literally haven't
done this for weeks now.
So we're going to have
a Hacker News BLoC.
So how I'm going to do
this is we will only
have one BLoC, which will
manage the state of, basically,
everything--
the content that we're showing.
So it will cache.
So it will do the
network requests.
It will cache them.
It will-- what else can they do?
Once we can implement
switching from top stories
to news stories,
it can manage that.
MATT: So it'll pull
different newsfeeds.
FILIP: Yep, Yeah.
MATT: So that, yeah, you are
kind of mixing responsibilities
a little bit there.
But because first cut, we're
going to keep things simple,
we're going to have
just one [? BLoC. ?]
FILIP: Yes, yes.
And as you may
know from our talk,
BLoC is a pretty simple class.
And there are some
rules that you
need to deal with, with BLoC.
The basic ones are all
the outputs are streams,
and all the inputs
are also streams.
So there's no synchronous
communication stream.
MATT: Stream in, stream out.
FILIP: Yeah.
Stream in, stream out.
Nice.
So this all going to be
called the HackerNewsBloc.
And so we're going
to have as subject--
so output of articles.
Yes?
OK.
So--
MATT: Why don't you talk
a little bit about what
a BehaviorSubject
is, and tell me
why that isn't a
stream controller.
FILIP: Oh, OK.
MATT: Because, typically, with a
stream, when I'm setting it up,
I would create a
stream controller.
And a stream controller
would give me
a reference to a stream,
but it would also
give me an Add method to
add things into the stream.
FILIP: That's true.
MATT: But you've got this
BehaviorSubject thing,
which does something different?
FILIP: Yes.
So the nice thing and also
a problem with streams
is that they're asynchronous,
while some things, especially
the [INAUDIBLE] method in
Flutter is synchronous.
And so using a stream
control would totally work,
but there would be one problem.
And that is that if there's a
change, for example, if Flutter
now builds something
and suddenly
wants to show a page
full of the articles,
it will be empty until something
about the articles changes.
What BehaviorSubject does is
whenever someone new listens
to it, the first thing it does,
it will send you the latest--
MATT: The last element
pushed into the stream.
FILIP: Yes.
Yes.
MATT: So stream controller,
I have to wait for something
to actively come
through the stream.
BehaviorSubject, as
long as one thing
has come through the
stream, I will always
get the previous value when I
start to listen on that stream.
FILIP: Correct.
I just realized that we need--
MATT: So where can we
find BehaviorSubject?
FILIP: Yes.
MATT: Because it's
not part of the SDK.
FILIP: It's not.
It's in--
MATT: RxDart.
FILIP: RxDart.
Yes.
Thank you.
See?
This is why you
have applications.
RxDart is now at 0.18.
So that's what we're going
to add to our pubspec.yaml.
RxDart.
We don't need this.
And get packages.
Right.
OK.
So we'll get, for some
reason, it doesn't--
RxDart.
OK.
MATT: Perfect.
FILIP: So we have that.
So this is one thing.
OK.
So let's just have that.
Let's just have one
output and no input.
We'll add an input shortly, but
this is all we need for now.
MATT: So, absolutely.
But I see here that you're
streaming a list of articles,
which means that
in the stream, it's
not going to be one
article at the time,
it's going to be a
list of articles.
Why aren't we just getting
one article after the other?
FILIP: Yeah.
So that would be
really hard for us.
We would have to have some kind
of business logic in our views
again to kind of
put it all together.
Because it wouldn't be--
you would never be sure when--
the list of articles
tells you, this
is all the articles from top
to bottom, how they are sorted.
And at the end of the
list, this is the end.
While if it was just
a stream of article,
you would never know, oh,
is this replacing the one
at the bottom, or at the top?
So that's why you want a
list, or something similar.
MATT: And this is following
one of the rules of BLoC, which
is pass to the UI what you're
going to represent in the UI,
and not have to have additional
business logic in the UI.
FILIP: That's right.
Yes, yes.
You don't want to force your
UI logic to do work for you.
You basically want to
push exactly what it needs
and nothing else, nothing more.
MATT: So while this may seem
a little counter-intuitive
or a little inelegant,
this is actually
going to make our UI code
very, very, very clean.
And there's nothing
stopping you from also
having a stream of articles
in the BLoC as well,
if there was a good
reason for doing that.
FILIP: Yes.
OK.
So we are going to rip
out things from here.
Think that's what we need.
So we'll keep the
hardcoded IDs for now.
So what you want to--
yeah, so when we get
to this getArticle,
instead of just
parsing and returning,
it will actually populate
the list of articles.
We can have, basically, a cache,
so that we don't always go to--
so what I'm going
to do is, there's
going to be a final variable
that is going to be private,
and it's going to
be called articles.
And that's going to be this.
You know, it's just going
to keep things simple.
And it's a list of articles.
MATT: OK.
So that initializes an
empty list of articles.
FILIP: Yes.
And then, oh, and we have
more business logic here.
We have this.
So we're mapping
over IDs, and then
getting articles
for each of the IDs.
MATT: Yeah.
And what we want
to do is we just
want to use a stream builder to
listen for the list of articles
when it's ready.
FILIP: That's right.
So I'm just going to have a
method here that gets all--
getArticle-- that's weird.
Get a list of--
ugh.
You know what, getArticles.
MATT: There you go.
FILIP: And that's
going to get these IDs.
And let's do it functionally.
So it will map over
them, over the ID itself.
getArticleID.
MATT: So we're going to
have a slight problem
here, because getArticleID
is asynchronous.
FILIP: Yes.
So this is now--
it's an iterable of
future of article.
MATT: And I think
there's a way in map
to wait for map to finish
after all the futures finish.
FILIP: Yes.
Yes.
MATT: I cannot remember
how to do that.
FILIP: That's why--
so this is the first--
expand.
MATT: Because, can you await--
FILIP: Yeah, that
would be great.
MATT: --in the map?
Map ID await getArticleID?
FILIP: Maybe not.
MATT: Let me have
a quick look here.
FILIP: So I know--
I think there is future wait.
Right.
So if you have an
iterable of futures,
and you want to
wait all of them,
you can do a future wait,
which is a static method
on the future class.
And it will return you a
future with a list of things.
So if we do--
OK, you know what?
So future articles is this.
We'll wait for the
future articles.
So final articles is this.
And then we'll just return it.
MATT: The articles
is going to be in--
so future articles returns
an iterator, not a list.
Because--
FILIP: That's true.
But fortunately, this
takes an iterable.
MATT: Oh, that's handy.
FILIP: Yeah.
MATT: So you don't
have to do any of the
to list that you typically have
to do when you're using lists.
FILIP: Yes, yes.
Yeah.
MATT: In list view.
That's nice.
FILIP: So I think
this should work.
So now we have that.
Oh, we didn't--
we will need this.
OK.
So we have this.
We have getArticles.
And now, all we need to do
is we are going to shoot--
when you create the
BLoC, it's going
to shoot this getArticles.
MATT: So getArticles
is going to give us a--
FILIP: You know what?
We can actually-- it's going to
give us the list of articles.
You know what?
We can actually do this.
It doesn't need to
give us anything.
It will just-- void.
And it will just assign
this to articles.
So it just updates, so maybe--
MATT: OK.
But you'll still need to
know when to push articles
into the stream.
FILIP: Yes.
So I'm just going to bail
out of this by using then--
wait--
MATT: Has no longer future.
Because you'll probably
want to return to future,
just so you know that
that's completed.
FILIP: That's true.
Yes.
So I'm going to return
a future of null.
And now I can--
then, that's going to be a
null value, so that's fine.
And then what we're
going to do is
we're going to add this
to the article subject.
MATT: You're going to
push the list of articles
into the stream.
Yeah.
FILIP: Right.
So if we were really
clean, we would make this--
maybe like, wrap it in
an unmodifiable list.
Because this makes it push the
actual articles list to the--
MATT: Yes.
So people could actually
modify the list,
and then that would modify
the list everywhere.
FILIP: Yes.
MATT: This should be a--
FILIP: Unmodifiable.
So let's do this.
Unmodifiable of articles.
This is not, like, super
performant, I guess,
because we're making a copy.
But I think there's an
unmodifiable view of the list,
if I'm not mistaken.
MATT: Built collection has
immutable collections as well,
which would be an option.
FILIP: Right.
Oh, no, no, no no.
Dart collection actually
has unmodifiable list view.
MATT: And that's a list--
OK.
FILIP: So that's
basically what we want.
That's in dart collection.
Dart collection.
And so now we have this.
It creates an unmodifiable
list backed by the source.
So it's not going
to have a copy.
It's just showing you this--
MATT: OK.
So it's not copying the
internals of the list.
OK.
OK, so theoretically,
now we have--
when we create the BLoC, at some
point in the near future, when
it's done all the
network pieces,
it is going to pump an
unmodifiable list of articles
into the stream, which
we can access through--
FILIP: The articles.
MATT: Which we can
[INAUDIBLE] through articles.
FILIP: All right.
So let's see if that works.
MATT: Oh, we're going to
have to change a lot of this.
FILIP: That's true.
So one thing I want to do here
is I'm going to pass it down.
So normally in our talk
at I/O, what we did was
we had this inherited widget
which it provided the BLoCs
to the widgets below.
We're not going to do it
today, because we have
a really shallow widget stream.
So what we can do is
just put the block down
through a
[? structure. ?] Right?
MATT: So we're going
to make MyApp--
so we're going to pass the--
and this is the
BLoC to MyApp, which
is going to pass an instance
of the BLoC to my homepage.
FILIP: So final hnBloc
is HackerNewsBloc.
And in the future--
MATT: K. There's no K in BLoC.
FILIP: Oh.
Oh.
Thank you.
In the future, we would actually
provide some kind of networking
to the HackerNewsBloc,
so we can even do that.
Right?
MATT: So we'd inject
some sort of--
so we could make it
testable at that point.
FILIP: Yes.
MATT: OK.
FILIP: All right.
So MyApp doesn't
yet get this, so we
need to create a constructor,
and that will take--
I can use BLoC.
Oh, you know what?
Maybe we want to do this.
final bloc, this.bloc.
So now we have--
oh, that's the app.
MATT: And now we need to pass it
down into my home page as well.
FILIP: Oh.
All right.
No problem.
MATT: This is why
we would recommend
for an app of any size
to use inherited widget,
because we have the flattest
tree imaginable with two
or three levels,
and already we're
having to pass through
constructor by constructor.
An inherited widget kind of
takes care of all that for you.
But for the time
being, this is great.
FILIP: OK, cool.
So we have it now,
accessible from here.
How do I--
I'm going to--
MATT: So our list
view, we're going
to want to wrap our list
view in a stream builder.
FILIP: Right.
We have the build item here.
OK.
So I'm just going to do this.
List view.
Yes.
You're right.
MATT: Because, yeah, we'll
need to wrap the widget.
FILIP: With a stream builder.
I think I have-- oh, so, live
templates, by the way, very
cool things in [INAUDIBLE].
MATT: Oh, yeah, you
told me about this.
FILIP: So I have one that's for
stream builders, S-T-M-B-L-D.
And that's going to be a stream
builder of unmodifiable view
of article.
MATT: Does exactly what
it says on the tin.
[LAUGHING]
FILIP: The stream is BLoC--
oh, no, no, it's in widget.
Widget BLoC--
MATT: Articles.
FILIP: Articles.
Initial data is nothing.
MATT: Do we-- we do
need initial data.
FILIP: Yeah, I mean.
Well, actually--
MATT: Theoretically, we
don't, because we can--
well, we could leave that.
But one way we could do
it is in the builder,
we could check to see if
the connection is waiting.
Then, we know that it's
actually streaming data.
FILIP: Right, right.
MATT: But let's keep
going with this.
FILIP: Yes.
So we have a list view, and
the children of it are--
let's do it functionally.
So we have the snapshot.
MATT: Mm-hm.
.data.
FILIP: Data.
Oh, I'm just going
to say, this is--
oh.
MATT: Whereas you don't have
to put the type explicitly in,
it helps the ID an
awful lot if you do.
FILIP: Yeah.
MATT: Oh, it's the whole thing.
FILIP: Yeah, so.
Unmodifiable list
view of article.
Well, OK.
MATT: We can tidy that up.
FILIP: And then the data
maps to some widgets.
And that could
just be buildItem.
Right?
So we're passing a function,
and that's that, I think.
MATT: There is a point,
though, with-- so it's
going to create the BLoC.
The BLoC is going
to some networking.
The BLoC is going to be created.
But at this point, the stream
builder is already building.
So maybe in this
scenario, there is
going to be no data
in the snapshot,
because the article
wouldn't have returned.
So do we have to check?
FILIP: Well, let's see--
MATT: That the
snapshot has data.
FILIP: Yeah.
I think because we are
providing initial data,
that it will always be--
MATT: It puts it in snapshot--
FILIP: Yeah, yeah.
Let's see.
I think we're there.
Oh, yeah.
BLoC.
All right.
[? help ?] [? restart? ?]
MATT: Now, because this is--
FILIP: So what we have
here, a value of type stream
can't be assigned to a
variable of type stream.
Oh, we're inputting
two different articles.
Is it possible?
Try changing the
type of the left--
MATT: Widget.bloc.articles.
FILIP: Main 60-- no, no.
Main 56 here.
Interesting.
Oh, you know what?
So we're hitting an issue here.
So here, we are importing
the article as package.
And here, I think, we're
inputting it as this.
So this is a really good
problem to happen upon
on this show, because this
can be really hard to debug.
You're like, why
is it complaining
about a different type
when it's the same type?
The thing is, currently
in Dart, there's
this thing that's
kind of infuriating,
is that when you import by
just a regular kind of path,
versus if you import somewhere
else by the package path,
it will assume it's different.
Because actually, it cannot
know in advance, I think,
that you're thinking-- it just
doesn't normalize this for some
reason.
MATT: I mean, theoretically, the
package could have been built
earlier, , and the source
code could have been changed.
What I typically do
is I force myself
to use the package,
the full-blown package
signature in the import.
FILIP: I can do that.
MATT: What do you typically to?
FILIP: I tend to do like, if
I'm in [? LEP, ?] I just do
everything not by package,
and everywhere else.
But what we have
here is just this.
All right, so--
MATT: Wait, did that just work?
FILIP: Yep.
It did.
MATT: Hot restart.
FILIP: It wasn't
even [INAUDIBLE]..
OK.
So it seems like-- let me
just restart everything.
All right.
MATT: Wow.
So we swapped out
the future builder
with the stream builder.
We moved all of the
code into the BLoC.
So we have all of our business
logic compartmentalized now.
And all the UI is doing,
as far as I can tell,
is it's like, hey, I'd like
a stream of list of articles,
please.
And I'll just render that.
FILIP: All right.
So that seems like we're
basically almost done.
So that was the
implementing of BLoC.
So now, over to you.
So I'm going to
push this to GitHub.
Get prepared to get
this from the latest.
Where's the--?
So implement BLoC.
And push.
We normally have this--
MATT: It's pushed?
FILIP: Yes.
MATT: OK.
So what I'm going to
need to do, I need to--
[? where ?] [? am I? ?] OK.
FILIP: We normally have all
this very amazing animation,
where we split places.
Or, split places--
switch places.
But we realize that it's kind
of dangerous, because then we
force the other person
to work with the ID
of the first person.
And especially with my
ID, I wouldn't want that.
MATT: Filip has a
heavily customized ID.
FILIP: Well, everyone has.
But, you know, mine
is kind of crazy.
MATT: So let me just resolve
a couple of merge things
that I was playing with earlier.
There we go.
OK.
So let's see if I have the--
so Filip was on the
Android Studio and--
FILIP: Yeah, Android Studio
and iPhone simulator.
MATT: So I got the
iPhone simulator,
but I am using
Visual Studio Code.
And I have some red BLoCs.
OK.
Behavior subject.
I need to get packages.
FILIP: Right.
MATT: So [? I can issue that ?]
from the command line.
FILIP: Yeah, Matt is all
about the command line.
MATT: I love me
some command line.
FILIP: I'm all
about [INAUDIBLE]..
MATT: What result just
get through some app thing
that you--
FILIP: I know, right?
MATT: OK, so I am
to do a hot restart.
There we go.
FILIP: That's amazing.
I'm still amazed that it works.
MATT: Yep.
I have the stream
builder, as you can see.
I've got unmodifiable-- the
first thing I'm going to do is
I am going to--
because it's been
driving me crazy.
[LAUGHING]
FILIP: All right.
Yes.
Details, but important details.
MATT: There we go.
FILIP: All right.
MATT: Hooray!
[LAUGHING]
OK.
So what would you like me to do?
What should we do next?
FILIP: Right.
So I would like us to be
able, as a user of this app,
to be able to somehow switch
between-- because in Hacker
News, you have all
these different views.
But what we really want to
just switch through right now
is the top and the new, right?
So sometimes you want to
read the newest stuff that's
happening in Hacker News.
But at least me, I like
to watch the top news.
MATT: OK.
So we could do that
a couple of ways.
We could have a
bottom navigation bar
with a couple of buttons,
which will fit between them.
I could put a toggle
button in a modal pop up,
or something like that.
FILIP: Yeah.
MATT: What do you think?
FILIP: What I think--
I actually-- I don't
have an opinion.
I'm not a designer.
MATT: If you're relying
on my design skills,
this is not going to go well.
FILIP: No, I think we
don't have that much time
to implement this.
So whatever is easiest
to implement right now.
MATT: So why don't
we start with just--
let's play around
with the scaffold,
and we'll stick in a
bottom [INAUDIBLE]..
FILIP: OK.
MATT: What I would
do at this point
is I would break out the
body into a separate widget,
and this, that, and the other.
But because we're manually
passing through the BLoC,
I don't want to have to
deal with passing BLoCs
further down.
So one of the things we get with
scaffolds, we have an app bar,
we have a body, we also have
a bottom navigation bar.
And a bottom navigation bar,
there's a couple of ways
we could do this.
I haven't implemented
one of these for a while,
so we'll see.
There's a-- oops.
Not a back button.
There's a bottom app
bar, which will give us
complete flexibility.
There's a bottom
navigation bar, which
will allow us to put icons in.
So if we put in a bottom
navigation bar, it's great.
What does it need?
It needs a list of bottom
navigation bar items.
So we are going
to give it items,
which is going to be a list.
List.
And I think that's all
it is required here.
So then what we
need to put in here
is a bottom navigation bar item.
And a bottom navigation
bar item is going
to require an icon and a title.
So a title will be top stories.
And I bet this is
going to be a widget.
So this is going to
be text of op stories.
FILIP: Yep.
MATT: And this is also
going to need an icon.
And so I am going to
give this an icon.
Icon.
Is there a news one?
News?
FILIP: Yeah, let's do this.
New releases looks good.
MATT: OK.
Let's just go new releases.
Now, I'm going to
have to close this up.
And--
FILIP: Items length
needs to be two.
MATT: We have to
have at least two.
FILIP: Ooh, interesting.
MATT: So we're
going to take this--
FILIP: That's good, because
we have exactly two.
MATT: We have exactly two.
New stories.
FILIP: Oh, you have top
stories and new stories.
Yeah, yeah.
We have the wrong icon
for the new stories.
MATT: OK.
Well, OK, so we'll
make this new stories,
and we'll make this icon.
There.
Top.
Because it points upwards.
If you want to find out
what all the icons are,
if you go over to Flutter and
search for icons, the Icons
Class, they are all in here.
FILIP: [GASPS] I
didn't know that.
MATT: Yeah.
And there are so many.
FILIP: They are actually
in the documents.
That's so amazing.
MATT: Yeah.
So you can scroll this
to your heart's content.
But let us get back to
where we are with this.
FILIP: It actually looks good.
I saw it--
MATT: Oh, there we go.
So now we have top stories
and we have new stories.
Now, one of the issues
with the bottom nav bar
is that you have to put a
little bit of logic in here.
FILIP: Right.
MATT: So, for example,
current index,
so we could do
current index of 1.
And what you'll see then
is this will highlight.
FILIP: Oh, OK.
MATT: But we need to handle the
on tap and the other pieces.
This is where it gets--
it can get a little bit messy.
But for each of these
bottom navigation bar items,
we do not have a tap.
What do we have here?
We have double.
We have on tap.
That's the on tap for the
bottom navigation bar item.
So how would I
typically do this?
FILIP: So this is
the like, UI logic,
so I'm fine with using
[INAUDIBLE] of something
like this.
We could just have, like,
what do they call it?
Current index?
MATT: I'm going to
go to the definition.
So we have a bottom
navigation bar.
That's fine.
And then in here,
we have an on tap.
This is called when
item is tapped.
And that gives us an
int, which is the index.
So what I can do
in here now is I
can go on tap, which is
going to be a function.
FILIP: Oh, the navigation
bar is in on tap.
OK.
That's good.
MATT: I think it does.
Wait.
I shouldn't put
that in my list of--
I should put that as just--
let's put this.
Yes.
FILIP: Oh, it will
give you an int.
OK.
That's clever OK.
MATT: And at this point,
what I would do in here is
I would put this in
a state for widget,
and I would have the index,
and I would switch between.
We might get to that,
but let's at least
get our on taps working.
So if index is 0,
print top stories
tapped, else print new stories.
OK.
So let's see what happens here.
So I'm going to
get rid of these.
There we go, top
stories and new stories.
FILIP: Oh, cool, cool, cool.
MATT: OK.
So that's good.
We are going to now want
to-- so if I hit Top Stories.
FILIP: So one way to do
this would be to just say
to have an input on the block.
And that input would
only accept, like,
top stories or new stories.
And from here, you would just,
like, do that, and that's it.
MATT: OK.
So let's take a look.
So we are going to check out
our-- what is your BLoC code?
FILIP: HN BLoC.
MATT: Oh, HN BLoC.
OK.
So our BLoC is here.
FILIP: You can just assume--
you don't need to
implement this.
Maybe even just assume there's
a stream controller or, like,
subject that you can
add to, and that's it.
MATT: So everything coming--
do we want to make this?
All the inputs are
streams, right?
FILIP: Yes, yes.
MATT: So we would want
an incoming stream
for updating the stories.
FILIP: Yeah, yeah.
MATT: So what would
that look like?
FILIP: That would be--
oh, yeah.
MATT: So I have a stream of--
let's get rid of this.
I have a stream of a modifiable
list of get articles.
So I would have a--
actually, what I would
have, I would have
a new behavior subject, right?
FILIP: You know what?
Just do the sync, sync of either
enum, or something like this.
And I will take care of the
underlying thing so that we
don't--
MATT: Why don't I
check this in, push it,
and then you
implement that piece,
and then I can finish it off.
FILIP: Oh, OK.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
MATT: Because
otherwise, you will be--
tell me what to
type next, Filip.
FILIP: Yes, yes, yes.
MATT: So--
[BEEP]
FILIP: All right.
So I'll just get this back.
And meanwhile, we realized
that we're actually
coming to one hour of Boring.
MATT: So let's see
what we can get
done in the next few minutes.
FILIP: Yeah.
OK.
MATT: So you want to deal
with an incoming stream,
so you're going to--
create a sync.
FILIP: Yes.
All right.
So this works.
MATT: Yup.
FILIP: So here, I'm
going to add a sync.
And I have another
handy template.
And that's going to be
a sync of stories type.
MATT: Oh, you're going
to make it an enum?
FILIP: Yep.
MATT: OK.
FILIP: And so it's a sync,
[? by ?] a stream control
for now.
Let's keep that.
I'm going to do the enum here.
So stories type.
So top and new for now.
Top stories and new stories.
New is a keyword.
New stories.
Right.
So we're accruing more
technical debt, as you can see,
by naming crazy and all that.
But that's fine.
And now, I just need
to listen to that.
So stories type.
Listen.
Stream, listen.
Sorry.
That's-- OK, so storiesType.
MATT: So what we
could do is we could
rename Update Articles to
Update Top Articles and update--
well, where are
you doing the call?
Basically, the only thing
we need to swap through here
is change the story URL.
FILIP: OK.
So we still have this.
So we still don't have what
IDs we're actually getting.
So this could take
a list of integers
that you will
actually want to get.
Right.
So list of int of article IDs.
MATT: Maybe we just want
to take the current list
and split it in half and
make one half top stories
and one half the other?
And that way, then
we can fix, we
can do the actual
networking next time.
FILIP: So this is now--
static list of-- let's
say this is new IDs.
And there's another one.
Static list int of top IDs.
Here by default, we're
doing the top stories.
So top IDs.
So that's the first one.
So when we create--
MATT: So it populates
it with top.
FILIP: And then here,
we're listening to that,
and we're doing--
so if stories type equals
stories type news stories,
then we'd just do
Update Articles.
MATT: Yup.
Because that will push a
new list into the stream.
And we don't care that it's
asynchronous, because it
will push through a stream.
FILIP: I just wonder.
We still need to push
the articles there.
Yeah, I just don't
want to repeat myself,
so I'm going to
do list int of IDs
is going to be undefined
by default. But--
MATT: I see what you're doing.
FILIP: This is going to be
new stories IDs, and else.
We could have a
switch [INAUDIBLE]..
Be probably nice.
Anyway, so IDs is top IDs.
And then , we could do
article subject at--
ooh, we still need to
get the actual articles.
MATT: Yeah, you just need to do
Update Articles with the IDs.
So basically, it's
that whole same piece
that you can just move into a--
FILIP: Get articles and update.
MATT: Your naming is accruing
so much technical data.
FILIP: I know.
OK.
Get articles and update.
MATT: Or we'll have to
[? pass them ?] the IDs.
There's going to
be a list of IDs.
FILIP: That's right.
Thank you.
IDs.
And here, then, we
can do exactly that.
You know what?
MATT: Yeah.
[LAUGHING]
FILIP: Oh, because, of course.
And this.
All right.
MATT: You can get rid
of the list of int IDs.
FILIP: Thank you.
MATT: OK.
FILIP: OK.
And now, let's see.
So are we actually
sending it there?
No, we're not.
MATT: No.
FILIP: Let's see
if it even works.
Because now we
should have only--
yeah.
MATT: So if you go
back into the bottom--
the nav bar, you should be able
to, instead of those prints,
you should just be
able to do widget.bloc.
FILIP: Right.
I'm just add this, because
I'm a little scared
about just having--
OK.
MATT: Can you tell I
used to write Python?
[LAUGHING]
FILIP: Widget BLoC,
stories type at--
and so if it's 0,
it's top stories.
MATT: Yes, it's going to be
stories, the top stories.
FILIP: And here, we
have new stories.
All right.
Let's do this.
Oh.
MATT: There we go.
FILIP: All right.
So--
MATT: We got a bunch
of things that we
need to tidy up
next session, which
is tracking the state
of the bottom nav bar,
or using a different control.
Actually, I kind
of like that one.
I think that looks pretty good.
FILIP: Yeah.
MATT: And we probably
want to tidy up--
we want to pull the
live feed of IDs.
FILIP: Right.
MATT: Those are relatively
straightforward to do,
but I'm afraid we're
out of time for that.
FILIP: Yup.
No, I'm very happy we
have a new functionality.
We put everything in BLoC.
We got rid of some of
the technical debt.
We accrued new one,
which is always great.
MATT: Just a tad.
FILIP: And so yes, well,
thanks for watching.
Please, if you have things that
you would like us to address,
or that are weird, or not
clear, please let us know.
We're aware of the
questions that you
ask on the tag for
"The Boring Show,"
we just don't have the
time to address them today.
But next time.
So don't worry about it.
We're still watching that.
MATT: We're accruing questions
debt, is what was done today.
FILIP: That's true.
Yes.
And also, Andrew is really
great in answering them
as they come in.
So don't feel like you have
to wait until our next episode
to ask and to get the answers.
All right.
So thank you for watching.
MATT: Thank you very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]